les soirées
j'appelle aussi
chanter pour lutter contre la morosité
voilà l'objectif du collectif respire à
figeac ce petit groupe de chanteurs
amateurs donne rendez vous aux habitants
de la commune du lot chaque samedi sur
la place du marché
il tente de redonner le sourire aux
passants face au contexte sanitaire et
social difficile lobée du collectif
c'était de fédérer les gens et puis
voilà on s'est retrouvés parce qu'on se
disait qu'on était tous inquiets de ce
qui était en train de se passer et on
voulait essayer de voir ce qu'on pouvait
faire à notre petit niveau de citoyens
pour amener un petit peu de joie aux
gens parce que c'était d'une morosité
incroyable il ya trois mois
et là ça commence à bouger un petit peu
les gens commencent à avoir de nouveau
le sourire à redon à danser à chanter
le but c'était juste ça en fait c'était
donner de la joie aux gens mais
l'événement festif a pris une autre
tournure samedi 20 février
la petite vingtaine de participants a
été prise à part par la police
municipale et la gendarmerie
le motif non respect du port du masque
dans une zone obligatoire et
rassemblement non autorisé sur la place
publique une intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir les passants c'est à la fois moi
je le porte le masque un jeu va papa
c'est malheureux mais je dire si on peut
veut pas payer une amende on est obligé
de le mettre mais ça empêche pas de
chanter ça empêche pas de faire plein de
choses je peux pas dire que je suis
d'accord avec ça
comment dire cette décision un peu
dictatorial d'aller mettre une prune à
quelqu'un qui essaye de mettre un peu de
joie de vivre
si deux amendes ont été distribuées
selon le maire de la commune cela n'a
pas freiné les membres du collectif
respire
au contraire ils étaient encore plus
nombreux ce samedi à chanter sur la
place du marché